the Joe Rogan experience Anthony Smith
fights home intruder man charged with
criminal trespass yeah you were telling
me about that apparently the guy was
tough too
like Smith said and smaller than him he
said the guy was like 170 pounds and the
guy took everything he could throw out
he's on meth said no normal human being
is is able to fight like that he said I
am by no means the baddest dude on the
planet listen he's top 100 oh no all the
humans on the planet Anthony Smith top
100 baddest [ __ ] in the earth
but he's a regular Joe and I had a hard
time dealing with him and he took
everything I gave him every punch every
knee every elbow he took every single
one of them and kept fighting me at one
point Smith said his mother-in-law
brought him a kitchen knife which she
held to have her man who continued to
fight him why did he just choke him
unconscious that's a legit point why
don't you just choke the [ __ ] out of
them yeah I just haven't said hey I'm
sorry as he walked by after things calm
down hey man I'm sorry I'm sorry tried
to kill you he said there was blood off
the computer and habberman was cut and
had swelling on his face yeah
did he but he didn't lay anything on
that thing they just beat the [ __ ] but
the guy took it the fact that the guy
only weighed 170 pounds and it says
Smith fights it 205 pounds he's walking
around 230 yeah he's he's smashing this
dude that's you know a legit 60 pounds
lighter than I'm which is crazy said
experience a wide range of emotions
afterwards I like Smith a lot he's a
very intelligent dude have you heard of
methanol yes really he has a future in
that future and he's got a future in
fighting too I want to you know I mean I
think after he fought John Jones he got
the rub and he looked fantastic
you look great with Gustafson know if
you remember that fight he could have
easily won that fight with that DQ he
remember that man I think John hit him
and they go do you want you want
continue fighting who do you want come
in he goes he hit him with a lone knee
all right I think is down you remember
that yeah it was a knee when he is down
and he goes you wanna stop the fight he
would have won the fight and he was
that's not my style
he just continued the fight that's
interesting I don't remember that yeah I
remember it vaguely he's a badass man he
is he's a very very smart guy what do
you if you're gonna act out and make the
news now is that
cuz like with John like way yeah like
what dude we're trying to not die
wouldn't give a [ __ ] what John's doing
there's a little bit of that right but
there's like we know about John angry we
know about John yeah but the world
doesn't even think no but like but like
even when Kobe's death like have you
heard anyone talk like that you before
this came that was it was so heavy with
Quran no one's really even mentioned it
we should were so focused on this
[ __ ] virus yeah yeah it's interesting
[Applause]